- Oh, hey mom, hey dad.
- Hi mom, hi dad!
- Hey mom, hey dad.
- Autumn's in the air
and you know what that means.
- I'm comin' home for the holidays.
- Thanksgiving.
- Christmas.
- New Years.
- Sleeping in my old bed again,
catchin' up.
- Just, being together as a family again.
- It would be a shame if
something were to come up
to ruin that,
like let's say,
Trump being elected president.
- Trump being elected president.
- According to the Atlantic,
90% of his supporters are white.
- And you guys are really white.
- Super white.
- I just needed to make sure
that you're not voting for him.
- You're not voting for him.
(light piano music)
- If Trump were elected president--
- I'd be pretty upset.
- People believe some crazy things.
- Some weird things.
- Like that climate change is a hoax
invented by the Chinese.
- And that Obama founded ISIS.
- And that the election is rigged.
- And that Donald Trump
is a good businessman.
- You know, things that
used to be crazy to believe.
- You know like, how it's
okay for a famous man
to grab a woman by her pussy.
- Our president,
a slub who thinks it's okay
to grab me by my pussy.
- Think about that dad,
my pussy.
- Or moms pussy.
You know how hard that was
for me to say, moms pussy.
Ouch.
- So I'll probably not
be leaving my home like,
ever again.
- I don't even know if I could come home,
thinking about President Trump.
- President Trump,
grabbing moms pussy.
- If Trump were in the White House,
do you think he would
have to go door to door
around the neighborhood saying, "Hi--
- "I'm a registered sex offender."
- No.
He wouldn't.
- Shame, shame, shame.
- So I'm not surprised if I'm jogging
and I'm running past the White House--
- And the man that lives there--
- Happens to grab my pussy.
- Dad my pussy.
- Moms pussy.
- If Trump is elected this year,
I'm having a friends-giving.
- Wouldn't that be a shame?
- If you guys voted for Trump--
- And I just couldn't come
home for the holidays anymore.
- None of us want that.
- Do we?
- On November 8th,
think about how badly you
wanna see me these holidays.
- 'Cause I wanna see you.
- But I wanna see Trump lose even more.
Love you!
- Love you guys!
- Okay, bye.
- Bye mom!
Bye dad.
- Who was that?
- It's Brad,
he wanted to know
if he can join our
family for Thanksgiving.
- Another one?
- Yeah it's, weird.